[Musique]
on a encore quelques amis vivaient
paisiblement des grenouilles et des
tritons mais depuis l'arrivée du train
les amphibiens ont dû faire leurs
valises lors de la construction de cette
ligne tours bordeaux il a fallu mettre
en place des mesures dites
compensatoires en bref si l'on détruit
l'habitat d'une espèce protégée on doit
recréer à proximité cet habitat sur des
surfaces deux fois pouvoir trois simples
grande sur cette ligne 223 espèces
protégées sont infectés ou comme ici aux
abords de la boivre une rivière qui
passe par la ville de poitiers on a fait
des travaux de génie hydraulique qui
sont des mesures de compensation à
destination du brochet est en général de
toute la faune piscicole ici on est sur
un site où il y avait un espèce de
barrage qui coupait la rivière en deux
et un signe on a rejointe et si je puis
dire les deux bouts du cours d'eau et on
offre un conte une continuité écologique
beaucoup plus importante pour le brochet
en particulier mais aussi pour toute la
faune piscicole du cours d'eau sur
l'ensemble de la ligne pour compenser la
destruction de la nature 3800 hectares
ont été restaurés maintenant l'étape
c'est le suivi des mesures mises en
place un travail qui s'inscrit dans le
temps long notre objectif c'est d'avoir
un projet à la biodiversité positive à
terme on voit qu'il ya des sites de
milieux naturels qui sont en permanence
conquis soit par l'agriculture soit par
l'artificialisation des terres
l'extension des agglomérations avec ces
mesures compensatoires que l'on
entretient pendant 40 ans on est sûr que
ces sites seront favorables à la
biodiversité
ce qui aurait pas forcément été le cas
s'il ce programme n'existe pas une
position nuancée par les associations de
protection de l'environnement qui
dénoncent des mesures parfois aléatoire
est trop optimiste si des mares ont été
créés pour accueillir nos amphibiens
déloger
on s'aperçoit que pour le moment on
retrouve un petit peu la diversité ça
qu'on retrouve quasiment les espèces qui
étaient 1 qui avait été inventoriés
initialement mais par contre en terme de
quantité on est très très très loin
encore du conte va falloir beaucoup de
temps pour que les populations
initialement présentes sur le secteur
puisse
s'installer à nouveau les perdurer
moment il faut ajouter à cela des
ouvrages parfois surprenants ici on a
créé ces tunnels passant sous la voie
pour permettre aux amphibiens de
traverser sans danger si certains
animaux rencontrés principe il utilise
ce ne sont pas être le cas des
grenouilles
malgré tout l'ensemble de ces mesures
compensatoires ont été validés par
l'état en novembre 2020 mais les
négociations ont été complexes des fois
c'était pas à pas toujours pas toujours
évident parce qu'il y avait aussi la
pression du porteur de projet pour faire
en sorte que ça lieu rapidement que con
que la compensation soit évalué aux
manières de manière minimaliste parce
que forcément il ya des enjeux
économiques derrière à la mise en place
des mesures compensatoires c'est aussi
un leurre dans le sens où tu as
compensation
avec 1
résultat zéro impact sur la biodiversité
ça n'existe pas quoi
[Musique]
son reportage de juliette gens je vous
fait réagir dominique bussereau parce
que vous connaissez ce coût
environnemental mais aussi les efforts
fournis par les associations on l'a vu
et par les concessionnaires des efforts
d'ampleur pour éviter de circuler au
gouvernement de la construction cette
ligne oui dans certains secteurs ce à
améliorer l'environnement dire qu'on est
passé de 2,2 l'an de dégoûtante mal
entretenu un passage en toute qualité
avec une reforestation des deux côtés
parfois très loin des passages pour le
gibier et honnêtement la blessure dans
le paysage d'une ligne tgv c'est
beaucoup moins qu'une ligne à haute
tension c'est moins certaines éoliennes
et c'est beaucoup moins qu'une autoroute
c'est un c'est pas si facile que ça
quand vous lirez ouvrir une autoroute
ferroviaire mais des camions sur des
wagons et pour empêcher les camions sur
la route heures mais avec des communes
qui disent non on veut pas parce que nos
passages à niveaux vont être fermés
toute la journée on n'en veut pas la
réouverture ou l'accélération du trafic
sur une ligne ferroviaire pose
aujourd'hui un certain nombre de
difficultés des composantes que vous
avez eu à affronter lorsque vous rédigez
votre rapport aux 6,1 effectivement je
vous l'avais déjà dire le réseau
français il fait près de 29 mille
kilomètres on tient un vrai enjeu aussi
à commencer par redévelopper le train
sur le réseau existant ce qu'on a la
chance d'avoir un réseau très dense on
sait par exemple qu on a environ 9
français sur 10 qui habitent à moins de
10 kilomètres d'une gare qu'on a déjà un
réseau qui est intensément maillet je me
permet de rebondir sur un autre point
quel est l'impact climatique de ces
constructions de ligne là il ya des
exemples intéressants notamment sur
dijon belfort il ya des études
évidemment qui ont été faites pour
évaluer l'impact climatique de cette
nouvelle ligne lgv est ce que l'on
constate c'est que le train est
tellement peu émetteurs par rapport aux
autres modes de transport que finalement
l'impact climatique de cette ligne là il
a été amorti en environ douze années ça
montre encore une fois que le train il
est vraiment moins émetteur et puis
surtout ça pose une question presque
lozeau fille j'ai envie de dire à savoir
où est ce qu'on met notre nos émissions
de carbone puisque on sait qu'on va être
limité en termes d'émissions de carbone
est ce qu'on le met dans des
infrastructures qui vont durer quarante
années qui vont servir pour de la lgv
mais pas école qui peuvent servir aussi
pour des trains de nuit pourquoi pas
pour du fret où est-ce qu'on le met dans
des avions court courrier qui volent
1h20 et puis ensuite c'est terminé sa
pose aussi ces questions là voilà c'est
tout cette philosophie du train que nous
prenons dans cette émission avec nos
invités pour l'illustrer et que ne
démentira pas notre invité dans ce tous
terre-à-terre elle publie un ouvrage
intitulé slow traite voilà à prendre
justement à ré envisager le train comme
une découverte douce et lente de
territoire
et voici le livre de notre invité
juliette la baronne dans ce tous
terre-à-terre bonjour juillet tanger
votre livre est un guide qui raconte les
histoires de ligne les histoires des
territoires une déclaration d'amour au
train à la gare aux territoires aussi le
tranquille réenchante le territoire de
40 ans de tgv ont vraiment façonner les
imaginaires l'idée c'était de parler
aussi des petits signes de celles qui
passent dans tous les villages qui sont
pas forcément dans des lgv mais qui
vraiment passe à côté des maisons dans
les tous les paysages de la paix qui
s'est extrêmement variés et l'idée était
prendre ces trains du quotidien de les
prendre à rebrousse poil finalement de
façon touristique de joigny à paimpol ou
de clermont ferrand à nîmes on va
prendre cet itinéraire un magnifique
épisodes cévenols par exemple alors
autour de 2,5 heures de train c'est tout
près de chez vous en faites vous avez
voulu aussi vous appuyez sur le maillage
qui existant en région pour donner envie
aux habitants de redécouvrir leur
territoire et leur patrimoine absolument
l'idée elle était en fait on peut se
dépayser à deux pas de chez soi et on
peut se dépayser en prenant un moyen de
transport finalement anciens qui a 150
ans et l'idée de le ré enchanter
vraiment ce cévenol qu'on appelle voilà
ce train qui va être clermont ferrand à
anime passe d'abord au sud de l'auvergne
et ensuite dans toutes les cévennes et
il traverse les territoires fantastique
on a l'impression parfois d'être au
canada et il ya des zones où ils
traversent des endroits où en fait il
n'ya pas d'habitations pas de routes non
plus donc ce qui permet d'avoir des
aperçus de territoire qu'on peut avoir
contre on peut aussi alterner avec de la
randonnée à pied ou à vélo puisque c'est
avec le transport permet une grande
multimodalité pensez aussi à ce pas de
côté privilégie le le train régional le
train de proximité alors c'est celui où
il n'ya pas de ya pas de prise forcément
y'a pas de wifi forcément mais c'est
aussi cet éloge du train avant que vous
mettez un petit peu en avant mais alors
j'avais envie de parler de sceptiques
ligne parce qu'elles ont été souvent
montrés du doigt comme étant coûteuse
voire d'arrière-garde moi j'ai emprunté
ses trains et de façon touristique mais
c'est également des lignes de vie qui
sont très importantes pour pour les
habitants qui sont dans ces territoires
il faut penser que tout on n'a pas les
moyens d'avoir une voiture tout le monde
ne peut pas conduire les ptt certaines
personnes âgées ont parlé du cévenol les
rondes sont extrêmement verglacée
l'hiver il ya des lycéens des personnes
qui n'ont pas encore l'âge de conduire
et le train ce patrimoine hérité de nos
ancêtres et qui a été vraiment construit
à coups de marteau enfin il faut quand
même se rendre compte qu'il ya des
tunnels qui ont été faits dans les
montagnes dans des conditions
incroyables au 19e siècle qu'il faut le
l'entretenir il faut lui rendre hommage
et il faut aussi se rendre compte que
voilà on a besoin de maintenir céline
disait avec ce livre c'était de
commencer à prendre par la main les
personnes pour les guider un peu au
début le raconter un peu l'histoire et
après elles font leur propre voyage
autour leur propre étape bravo vous avez
dû faire parce que vous avez rédigé ce
livre avant l'épisode qu'ovide ce qui
nous a poussés justement à redécouvrir
les trésors de proximité au sortir de la
maison à l'heure où il disait c'est un
guide c'est aussi un petit peu votre
philosophie manifeste aussi du train et
de la lenteur du train pour redécouvrir
la france de notre france l'autre haine
chez arthaud merci beaucoup plus liette
mais la semaine ce cri du coeur et ce
guide formidable
voilà qu'on se livre entre guider et
manifeste qui nous propose une trentaine
d'échappée ferroviaire cela vous fait
réagir dominique bussereau car en dehors
de tout votre itinéraire d'un homme
politique vous occupez aujourd'hui de
train touristique lettre un touriste et
que c'est formidable un existe plus de
90 en france sont gérés par des
associations par des collectivités par
les entreprises moi je m'occupe de deux
d'entre eux l'unc et le train des
mouettes alors c'est une ancienne ligne
qui suit un fleuve côtier là ce droit en
charente-maritime et qu'il a de saujon
près de royan à la tremblade quasiment
jusqu'à l'océan gris traversant les
anciens marais salants et c'est avec des
locomotives à vapeur dont certaines sont
classées monuments historiques la plus
ancienne à 130 ans ce sont souvent des
objets patrimoniaux bien sûr ce sont des
trains d'histoire qui ne roulent pas à
l'hydrogène vers encore un nom et roule
ces périodes là le vapeur c'est pas fort
allez alors du train passion au train
innovations qui nous intéresse aussi va
longtemps des fontaines le train à
hydrogène tenez en a la sncf vient de
passer commande à alstom des 12 premiers
trains à hydrogène français ce sont des
technologies d'avenir mais c'est
l'avenir pour vous de ce train si tu
aurais peut-être sur un point
l'hydrogène vers ça veut dire de
l'hydrogène qui est produit avec des
énergies renouvelables ce qui veut aussi
dire qu'on n'aura pas d'hydrogène pour
tous les modes de transport pour tous
les usages et en ce moment on parle
beaucoup d'hydrogène on en parle pour
beaucoup de choses à l'hydrogène l'enjeu
c'est de le mettre là où on n'a pas
tellement d'alternative par exemple dans
le transport maritime on sait qu'on a on
met de limiter sur les alternatives ça
peut être une bonne solution sur le
transport routier pour certains
véhicules ça peut être aussi une
solution ça peut l'être aussi pour le
train mais c'est une technologie qui
coûte cher ben attention à ce que ça ne
se fasse pas au détriment de
l'investissement notamment dans le
réseau et puis à d'autres solutions
notamment les trains bi-mode donc être
un bi mode sondés d'être a en fait avec
des batteries et donc par moments on
roule sur le réseau électrique classique
et puis quand il n'ya pas de caténaires
et on va rouler sur les batteries et ça
c'est très intéressant ce camp est ça
permet de réduire considérablement le
coût de l'électrification du réseau
bien compris c'est secondaire par
rapport aux maillages qu'il nous faut
densifier aujourd'hui et sur une céline
du quotidien sur lequel insiste votre
rapport le fils et petit fils de
cheminot que vous êtes dominique
bussereau est plutôt optimiste justement
sur la vertu du train le chemin de fer
est vraiment au coeur du 21e siècle
simplement il faut le financer donc ça
passe par le fait que les clients
acceptent de payer quand même un prix
convenable il faut aussi parfois un
financement des entreprises et un
financement des collectivités l'état n'y
arrivera jamais et donc les régions les
départements les collectivités tout le
monde doit participer au financement il
faut aussi que l'état ne desserre un peu
la bride à nous les collectivités pour
tout puissant dégager encore plus
d'argent pour développer les transports
publics conclusion porteuse d'espoir
merci dominique bussereau mercier
valentin des fontaines alors je vais
vous signaler trois livres le premier
que nous évoquions dans ce tous terre à
terre selon trend cet éloge de la
lenteur par le train 30 et itinéraires
pour voyager autrement en train voilà
aussi de circonstance pour parcourir
l'europe confortablement installés aussi
le paysage défilant par la fenêtre celui
que nous a évoqué il ya quelques
instants avec les trains touristiques
dominique bussereau et puis c'est là
c'est l'histoire en marche
l'orient-express et compagnie livre de
photos livres d'histoire voilà en
réalité il ya assez peu de livres sur le
train de demain donc à nous décrire les
pages de ce transport d'avenir merci
beaucoup à vous tous d'avoir suivi cette
émission sur le train transporte de
demain merci au comptoir général près du
canal saint martin à paris de nous
accueillir ce lieu est aussi porteur des
valeurs que nous mettons régulièrement
dans notre émission terre-à-terre
émission qui tournait en partie avec des
smartphones alors on applaudit la
technologie se sont aussi matériels
extrêmement polluant qu'ils font aux
cycles et merci de votre fidélité merci
nous accompagnait régulièrement cette
émission qui est la vôtre
[Musique]
revoir ce programme en replay sur
publicsenat.fr
ah oui bonjour
98,1 points 70
chez nous annoncé à chelsea
ça vous a souvent ça les éléments d'une
croissance pense que
ça s'arrête pas du tout
récemment
sur les routes de nos vies samedi à 21h
sur public sénat
[Musique]
la sono
2 oui oui
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur bonjour je viens pour
faire ma dose de rappel
il y a des rendez vous à ne pas manquer
pour continuer à vous protéger penser
dès maintenant à votre dose de rappel
rappel et des variants me creed de la
communication du gouvernement entre
confiance et alerte décryptage dans en
même temps cette semaine dans estag
acheté samedi à 18h sur public sénat
[Musique]
je suis rarement teenag anime la
matinale de public sénat c'est tous les
jours de 7h30 à 9h et sa peine pour nous
chez vous
thomas hugues
journaliste mon émission s'appelle sens
public c'est tous les jours du lundi au
jeudi 18h 19h30 sur public sénat que
yann mathieu croissandeau
liste des intervenants l'émission to my
hood où s'enfuir
[Musique]
elizabeth martichoux
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition en direct du sénat
votre nouveau programme pour suivre
l'actualité de la chambre haute du
parlement avec cette semaine pas moins
de cinq sujets sur lesquels nous
proposons de revenir et tout d'abord la
situation sanitaire et cette croissance
fulgurante du nombre de cas le sénat
auditionné cette semaine trois
spécialistes du coc vide 19 on en
parlera avec roger karoutchi le
rapporteur de la mission d'information
au sénat sur le confinement et on
écoutera également la directrice
générale de l' agence du médicament qui
est revenu sur un sujet très important
ce sont les effets indésirables des
vaccins parmi les autres grands sujets
au sénat cette semaine le lancement de
la commission enquête sur la
concentration dans les médias on en
parlera avec le rapporteur socialiste
cette commission david assouline et on
écoutera également le directeur général
du groupe bouygues à propos d'un
rapprochement celui de tf1 et de m6
ensuite nous reviendrons sur l'audition
de l'ancien ministre de la justice c'est
isabelle guigou au sénat est là et bien
rédigé un rapport sur la présomption
d'innocence on en parlera avec le
sénateur jean pierre sueur de la
commission des lois du sénat et enfin
retour dans la vallée de la roya en fin
d'émission des sénateurs se sont rendus
au chevet de cette vallée un peu plus
d'un an après la catastrophe qui était
lié à la tempête alex
mais tout d'abord la situation sanitaire
gabriela talent hier en sortie du
conseil des ministres a parlé d'une
croissance fulgurante du nombre de
cadres qu'ovide avec une moyenne de 32
mille cas par jour et une pression
hospitalière qui augmente nettement ça
tombe bien cette semaine au sénat trois
spécialistes du comité 19 étaient reçus
par une mission d'information on les
écoute et on en parle juste après avec
roger karoutchi
sur les écoles c'est en particulier la
situation dans les écoles élémentaires
maternelles et les crèches sur la ville
dans la ville de paris parce qu'une
dernière mercredi avec 357 classes
fermées il y en avait que 8 qui était
collège ou lycée donc c'est vraiment
dans ce qui se passe à l'école
élémentaire et c'est assez logique
puisque c'est l'endroit où il ya la plus
grande proportion de personnes non
vaccinées puisque pour l'instant les
enfants en école élémentaire ne peuvent
pas être vaccinés la vaccination n'est
pas ouverte dans notre pays donc il me
semble que alors que les incidents sont
plus haut et en particulier donc dans
les écoles élémentaires avec des taux
qui dans certains départements dépassés
ou
alléger le protocole les fermetures de
classes plutôt que de passer à un niveau
3 ou 4 du protocole montre que le seul
objectif est la non fermeture des
classes et non pas le contrôler
l'épidémie et avec le contexte de
nouveaux variants je pense que c'est
donner une excellente opportunité
auvergne en micro
si les plus france me cible est bien de
se répandre rapidement l'ensemble de la
population
ça me paraît une très très mauvaise idée
on sait aussi que à l'école élémentaire
ce qui est le plus efficace ce serait de
faire des tests répétés parce que les
tests réactif ça permet d'éviter des
fermetures de classes mais ça ne permet
pas de diminuer la transmission
mais les expérimentations qui était
prévu là je sais par exemple qu'à paris
ça commence seulement cette semaine et
seulement dans les écoles voilà on se
dit que c'est quand même pas à la
hauteur de ce qu'il faudrait faire
compte tenu des chiffres d'incidence que
j'ai rappelé et je veux rappeler aussi
que on a souvent traduit le moindre
risque chez les enfants comme si ça
voulait dire pas de risque mais en date
d'hier il y avait 69 ans de 0 à 9 ans
hospitalisée
53 de 10 à 19 ans
et depuis le début de l'épidémie il n'y
a eu que 13 décès jusqu'à l'âge de 19
ans il y en a eu neuf depuis mi juin et
3 dans les 10 derniers jours donc
ça me paraît devoir être souligné
personnellement je ne vois pas pourquoi
on doit accepter que des enfants meurent
même si c'est pas beaucoup et je ne
parle même pas des séquelles à long
terme
c'est toujours eu un peu une nébuleuse
en termes de qu'elle ferait que traction
des personnes infectées en sont
atteintes et en particulier chez les
enfants mais tout de même le coville
l'on est une problématique également on
met aussi la charge pour les enfants de
ce2 peut-être se dire qu'ils peuvent
contaminer des gens fragiles de leurs
emplois je ne crois qu'il faut pas les
faux pas l'oublier non plus
et puis avec cette situation qu'on
décrit dans les écoles même si les
écoles sont ouvertes il ya quand même
beaucoup d'absences certains enfants qui
sont absents certains professeurs qui
sont absents et par conséquent une
situation scolaire qui n'est quand même
pas totalement conserver donc il me
semble que la vaccination des enfants de
5 à 11 ans doit être possible maintenant
qu'elle a été approuvée par l'agent sont
appelés in big allemagne à un avis de la
hs maison qui dit qu'il faut l'ouvrir
aux enfants à risque avec une définition
assez large sud qu'est ce qu'ils
appellent à risque et puis aussi qui qui
dit qu'ils vont faire des consultations
avant de donner à la vie parce que il ya
beaucoup de réticences mais nous ne
sommes que ça devrait pouvoir être
possible qu'il ne pas dire de rendre
obligatoire depuis 18 mois dans la
plupart des services de maladies
infectieuses et beaucoup de service de
médecine interne on a continué à prendre
en charge des patients affectés par la
coved 19 et qu' on est on a vu au jour
le jour changer le profil de ces
patients jusqu'à la vaccination
évidemment c'était tout un chacun alors
bien sûr avec quelques facteurs de
risque supplémentaire mais on a vu des
personnes tout à fait bien portante sans
facteur de risque est hospitalisé puis
certains passaient en réanimation est
décédé depuis qu'on a accès à la
vaccination le profil a énormément
changé
80% des personnes qui arrivent à
l'hôpital avec une copine 19 ne sont pas
vaccinés et c'est celle qui sont
majoritairement les patients qui passent
en réanimation et qui décède les 20% à
peu près de patients qui sont vaccinés
qui arrivent malgré tout à l'hôpital
sont des personnes qui ont des facteurs
de risque dans particulier d'autres
comme mobilité et surtout qu'ils ont une
deuxième dose qui est assez éloignée en
général 5 6 mois voire plus de leurs
nouvelles infections donc on voit bien
que la vaccination en tout cas dans le
contexte du delta a vraiment bien marché
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui a permis et
c'est ce que l'on voit actuellement
malgré l'augmentation très brutal delà
de la transmission nous ne sommes pas
submergés nous avons plus de travail
nous avons recommencé la réunion des
cellules de crise nous commençons à
ouvrir d'autres lits mais nous ne sommes
pas submergés et j'aurais pu penser que
en faisant abstraction du possible
impact de l'eau microns on aurait pu
faire face à sète à cette quatrième
vague au niveau hospitalier donc je le
rappelle vraiment en a tendance à dire
parce qu'on a des cas de personnes
vaccinées à l'hôpital le vaccin ne
marche pas qu'en aurait-il été si on
n'avait pas eu la vaccination
évidemment là où également les choses
changent et on voit bien qu'on est au
collet qu'on est dans une détérioration
de la situation recommence à avoir
quelques cas de transmission nosocomiale
donc en particulier de familles qui
viennent visiter des patients
hospitalisés qui leur transmettent
l'infection on a également quelques
membres du personnel soignant mais pour
l'instant pas du tout de l'ampleur de ce
que l'on a pu avoir avant donc ce qui
prouve bien que la vaccination change
tout de même permet de soulager
l'hôpital en tout cas de la peintre
d'investissement sur la colline 19 en
revanche que l'on voit c'est qu'on est
bien sûr en tension à cause de toutes
les pathologies hivernales et en
particulier d'une population âgée qui
est qui a été très vulnérable
vulnérabiliser par la pandémie en ce qui
concerne l'actualité thérapeutique
on a fait d'énormes progrès en 18 mois
on a maintenant des molécules dont on a
évalué l'efficacité dont on a prouvé
l'efficacité dans le cadre d'essais
thérapeutiques de recherche bien
conduite sur le plan méthodologique mais
également sur le plan éthique qui par
exemple permettent d'améliorer la prise
en charge des personnes hospitalisées
avec des formes graves des
immunomodulateurs qui sont rentrés dans
la panoplie des traitements qui sont par
exemple recommandé par l' oms mais
également par nos instances de
recommandation mais évidemment
l'utilisation de ces traitements à
l'hôpital n'a aucun impact sur la
dynamique de l'épidémie ne permet que de
diminuer la mortalité et quand vous
regardez d'ailleurs l'évolution de la
mortalité sur ces 18 mois elle a fort
heureusement baissé ce qui prouve qu'on
a vraiment amélioré la prise en charge à
l'hôpital
à côté de ces immunomodulateurs qu'on va
utiliser à l'hôpital on a développé
toute une panoplie de médicaments
antiviraux alors on a des antiviraux qui
vont se prendre par la bouche qui sont
donc destinés à la médecine ambulatoire
est pour l'instant ces médicaments ce
d'ailleurs un d'entre eux est évalué ce
soir par la évier et puis ils vont très
prochainement faire l'objet d'une
évaluation par la has on en a
actuellement deux mais d'autres qui vont
être évalués bientôt et puis d'autres
vont arriver on espère si tenté que l'on
montre qu'effectivement ils vont avoir
un impact avec les données qui nous
devons nous est montré qu'on ne connaît
pas encore un et bien on peut
probablement envisager que la médecine
ambulatoire puisse jouer vraiment un
grand rôle dans le traitement des formes
précoces donc avant que les patients
arrivent à l'hôpital puisque le but de
ces médicaments ça va être d'éviter que
les patients arrivent à l'hôpital
évidemment qu'il décède et à côté ces
antiviraux depuis plusieurs semaines je
dirais même mois nous avons à notre
disposition des anticorps monoclonaux
qui ont trois indications préférentiels
d'abord celle et donc tout chez des
personnes qui sont à risque de faire des
formes graves soit parce qu'ils ont déjà
des symptômes des modérés soit parce
qu'ils ont été exposés quelqu'un qui
était prouvée malade soit en pré
exposition quand il ya un échec de
vaccination il faut dire que pour
l'instant ces anticorps monoclonaux sont
sous utilisés que c'est vrai que la
procédure pour y avoir accès et
relativement lourde est alors
qu'initialement les destinées plutôt à
la médecine de ville la lourdeur de
l'accès fait que c'est plutôt à
l'hôpital même dans les structures
ambulatoires mais l'hôpital qu'on les
utilise donc il faudrait vraiment qu'on
fasse un effort pour les rendre plus
facilement disponibles
le futur alors le futur là aussi je
dirais que de tirer de mon expérience
hospitalière je peux vous dire que les
patients qui ne sont pas vaccinés ne
sont pas des personnes ne sont pas tous
et c'est même je dirais une partie
extrêmement minoritaire des personnes
vaccinées absolument contre le vaccin à
chaque fois que je fais la visite dans
mon service que je questionne ces
personnes qui arrivent non vacciner à
l'hôpital avec une copie de 19 et de
l'oxygène beaucoup me disent qu'ils y
acquis qu'ils ont qu'ils ont sous-estimé
bon évidemment l'importance de
l'infection qu'ils attendaient ça c'est
vrai pour les personnes âgées que leur
médecin généraliste les contacts que
c'était parfois des personnes qui
étaient en situation de vulnérabilité
parce que il était migrants etc etc et
que on voit bien qu'on a encore un
effort à faire couvert là les verts il y
un problème également est la troisième
cause puisque les personnes qui ont déjà
de dos qui arrivent à l'hôpital n'ont
pas eu cette troisième dose et
effectivement on a maintenant des
données solides pour montrer que le
l'efficacité de la vaccination diminue
non seulement chez les personnes à
risque mais aussi chez tout le monde
d'où l'importance et j'en suis très
contente même si je pense que ça arrive
un peu tard que la troisième dose a été
étendu à tout le monde parce
qu'évidemment cette troisième dose
permet d'éviter le passage de
l'hospitalisation mais elle diminue
aussi la durée des symptômes et
l'importance de la réplication virale
donc on peut penser que ça diminuerait
la transmission
et je dirais qu'il faut poursuivre
l'effort de recherche extrêmement
important évidemment termes de
traitement mais également en termes de
moyens mis sur le séquençage alors il ya
eu beaucoup de progrès qui ont été faits
en un an et demi mais on aurait envie
qu'il y ait encore plus de séquençage
fait sur tout le territoire pour pour
pouvoir identifier très rapidement les
souches qui pose problème est peut-être
si vous me le permettez je
ne reviendrai pas sur l'importance des
pays du sud on voit que le que ce soit
le delta où que ce soit l'eau mikron ce
sont des variantes qui émergent dans des
populations non vaccinés ou le virus se
multiplie longtemps à bas bruit ou qui
sont également des pays où il ya
beaucoup de personnes immunodéprimées et
quand on regarde l'impact de la
couverture vaccinale dans le monde
entier tous les continents sauf
l'afrique sont à quasi 65 % de
couverture vaccinale l'afrique 10% et
l'avenir de l'europe et du monde entier
ne se jouera pas sans celui de l'afrique
en ce qui concerne l'efficacité du môle
du pire à dire
vous m'aviez demandé alors en fait vous
savez ce qui est très compliqué avec ces
logiques industrielles c'est d'avoir
accès aux données
publiées dans des journaux revues par
les pairs c'est à dire avec un regard
critique scientifique qui permet de
remettre les choses à leur place alors
juste place dans l'environnement global
sans avoir de pression de qui que ce
soit et en particulier de l'industrie
pharmaceutique pour l'instant on nous a
demandé de nous prononcer sur des
données issues de communiqués de presse
ça rend toujours les données très
parcellaires et pour moi impossible à
analyser évidemment nous ne sommes pas
des experts de la sdl je ne suis pas une
experte de la chaise qui ont eu ou vont
avoir
accès à ces données et vont se prononcer
en connaissance de cause donc pour
l'instant c'est difficile de dire si ces
traitements sont efficaces et si on va
les utiliser à grande échelle en tant
que scientifique on espère que dès que
des traitements antiviraux puisse
changer la donne dans la prise en charge
ambulatoire c'est-à-dire en dehors de
l'hôpital de de l'infection donc je
pense qu'il faut attendre que les
experts de la has a lors de la veillée
ce soir pour certaines de ses molécules
et puis dans un dans un très proche
avenir de la chasse et on peut avoir
confiance en deux pour nous montrer
voilà si ces molécules sont efficaces
voilà pour cette audition de trois
spécialistes du coït 19 qui étaient
reçus au sénat avant-hier pour en parler
j'ai accueilli six ans à la conférence
roger karoutchi bonjour c'est vous le
rapporteur de cette mission
d'information du sénat sur les
confinements alors au vu des dires de
ces spécialistes question toute simple
est ce qu'on va vers un nouveau
confinement excès cinquième bague
n'allant pas n'allons pas désespérer
tout le monde tout de suite ce serait
quand même dramatique j'espère bien que
non j'espère bien que non on n'a pas
lancé toutes les campagnes de
vaccination la campagne pour le rappelle
on n'a pas avancé quand même sur les
traitements y compris hospitalier pour
se retrouver encore en situation de
confinement comme il ya un an un an et
demi non j'espère qu'on évitera le
confinement j'espère qu'on évitera les
mesures les plus sévères à savoir le
couvre-feu à savoir la fermeture des
magasins mais pour le moment ce qui ne
nous rassure pas c'est que la vague est
beaucoup plus brutale que même les
spécialistes ne l'attendait oui à parler
de croissance fulgurante du nombre de
quatre ce qu'on retient aussi dans cette
audition quand on l'a écouté c'est la
prudence des spécialistes notamment sur
le variant omicron il faudra encore
attendre quelques semaines pour savoir
si ce variant déstabilise l'efficacité
des vaccins encore un an et demi après
le but de cette épidémie il ya beaucoup
de choses qu'on n'arrive pas à
comprendre sur le comique c'est ça aussi
qu'on attend c'est une certitude c'est
que
on avance ensemble si je puis dire alors
les scientifiques ne sont pas tous
d'accord on arrive à peu près un certain
nombre d'éléments stable sûre quand même
les effets la vaccination qui ont des
effets positifs même si les anti vaccins
ont des arguments mais pas sur les faits
réels de la vaccination on arrive à des
éléments stables sur les traitements
hospitaliers sur la capacité des
hôpitaux à mieux traiter les malades et
à faire en sorte de ne pas aller
systématiquement outreau vers les soins
d'urgence ouverts les réanimations mais
à côté de ça il ya beaucoup d'inconnues
le nouveau variant omicron certains
disent ils est beaucoup plus contagieux
est plus virulent d'autres disent ils
non il est pas plus contagieux que le
delta et il ne l'emportera pas sur le
delta attendons de voir ça par
définition on ne le saura que dans les
semaines qui viennent revenons à ce fort
pic de contamination liée aux variantes
delta karine lacombe à noter que
l'hôpital n'était pas surchargé pour
l'heure elle note quand même que 80 %
des patients ne sont pas vaccinés on
leur dit c'est la clé de voûte de la
sortie de crise la vaccination
je peux comprendre que des gens n'est
pas confiance ou se disent les arn ça ne
me rassure pas et tout mais les chiffres
sont là si vous voulez aujourd'hui
80% des gens qui sont hospitalisés ne
sont pas vaccinés et quand on sait qu'il
n'ya que 20 % en fait de la population
qui n'est pas vaccinée on se dit si 20%
non vaccinés de l'ain 80% des
hospitalisés c'est quand même l'élément
qui prouve que les gens vaccinés sont
plus protégés voilà alors je dis pas que
c'est le leu leu que le vaccin est un
miracle universel il faut évidemment
quand même encore redire les gestes
barrière le gel hydroalcoolique ne pas
s'embrasser ne pas serrer les mains ne
pas se retrouver avec des centaines de
personnes dans dédé des réunions sans
masque et tout c'est quand même ça la
base du du de ce qui peut permettre de
ne pas avoir de vagues roger karoutchi
nous reste deux minutes évoquons le
nouveau protocole dans les écoles
pourquoi parce que dominique costagliola
au cours de cette audition où vous étiez
elle a dit que ce nouveau protocole en
les écoles donne je cite une excellente
opportunité omicron s'il est plus
transmissible de se répandre rapidement
dans l'ensemble de la population ça me
paraît être une très très mauvaise idée
fin de citation qu'est ce que on peut
dire et ce protocole il n'est pas assez
prudent je trouve moi je pense je suis
pas médecin mais je trouve que les
modifications et les variations si je
puis dire de de la part du ministère de
l'éducation qui au début disait enfin au
début ils ferment à la rentrée c'était
encore un cas dans une classe on ferme
la classe mais aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est bon après tout ouest
pour ne pas avoir 8000 ou dix mille
classes fermées comme ce
qui évidemment impressionne le public on
dit plus on ferme les classes ont dû aux
tests mais en réalité on y des choses
claires et donc je reconnais que
espérant que l'eau mikron ne soit pas
effectivement plus transmissible mais ça
n'est pas à mon sens ça n'est pas une
mode c'est peut-être une mesure pour
laisser les classes ouvertes faire en
sorte que les élèves à aller à l'école
ça n'est pas une mesure sanitaire très
utile et donc vous appeler jean michel
rocard à revenir en ayant ce que vous vu
l'importance de la vague je pense que le
ministère de l'éducation devrait revenir
sur ce protocole et et réétudier les
choses avec les spécialistes pour voir
si justement la transmission se faisant
malheureusement beaucoup par les enfants
qui n'ont pas de conséquences lourdes
sur le co vide mais qui transmettent il
faut être extrêmement prudent un dernier
mot très rapide sur la vaccination des 5
11 ans on a entendu la commission
européenne annonce et les doses diluée à
partir du 13 décembre
pour l'instant on se réserve la
vaccination de ces enfants uniquement
pour ceux qui sont à risque est-ce qu'il
va falloir aller plus loin là encore
je serai autant je suis favorable à la
vaccination autant va vacciner les 5-11
ans ça me paraît je pense qu'il vaut
mieux des protocoles plus sévères dans
les écoles pour éviter la transmission
une vaccination obligatoire des gamins
vraiment eh bien merci merci roger
karoutchi pour cette réaction à notre
micro et en sueur uns les autres travaux
de la mission d'information qui doit
rendre un rapport moi je pense que nous
ferons encore des auditions mois de
décembre et il y aura un rapport à peu
près circonstancié au mois de janvier
merci roger karoutchi
allez on continue avec cette crise
sanitaire car au sénat cette semaine la
directrice générale de l'agencé
nationale de la sécurité du médicament
et des produits de santé à brosser un
panorama des principaux effets
secondaires signalés en france depuis le
début de la campagne de vaccination on
en écoute énormément préparé par alice
bardot
et vous vous interrogez sur la
sous-déclaration en pharmacovigilance
qui en effet est une question récurrente
et on le sait il y a une sous
déclaration en pharmacovigilance mais en
moins sur cette campagne d'une ampleur
inédite nous sommes à la mi novembre à
plus de 110000 déclaration d'effets
indésirables pour vous donner un ordre
de grandeur les années sans pandémie si
je puis dire on est plutôt autour de 45
mille événements indésirables qui sont
enregistrées dans la base nationale de
vigilance donc tout médicament
confondues exactement alors que la sur
les seuls effets indésirables des
vaccins on est à plus de 110000 germi
bien même s'il gagne sous déclaration on
est quand même très largement informé la
surveillance porte véritablement sur
l'ensemble des effets juste quelques
caractéristiques également sur ses
échecs c'est vrai que en règle générale
pareil la déclaration est
majoritairement sept ans par les
professionnels de santé du fait de la
proximité notamment les centres
régionaux de pharmacovigilance des
professionnels de santé au sein des
centres hospitaliers universitaires
là on le voit au lieu d'être a autour de
90% de déclaration par les
professionnels de santé il ya un
rééquilibrage on a beaucoup plus de
déclaration par les patients on est en
train de regarder les chiffres on pourra
vous les donnez plus tard mais c'est
sans doute de l'ordre de 40 60 % 40 % de
patients contre 10% d'habitude et de
fait sur la répartition également entre
les cas graves et les cas graves là
aussi on est habituellement sur une
répartition qui est
autour de
40% de
2,2
pardon il faut que je reprenne mais là
on a beaucoup plus grave majoritairement
grave en temps normal et là on n'a plus
une déclaration de d'événements non
graves donc on le voit on a une
surveillance qui fonctionne à la fois
pour les effets indésirables graves et
les noms grappes juste pour revenir sur
ce critère de gravité
parce que ça peut engendrer des
problèmes d'incompréhension la gravité
en pharmacovigilance elle est analysée
au regard de certains critères par
exemple si on est hospitalisé s'il a une
maison j'ai dû prône aussi vite à l'eau
ou un décès mais il ya aussi un critère
qui est un critère qui est du fait du
professionnel de santé qui va lui jugé
que c'est médicalement que l'effet est
médicalement grave et donc de ce fait
c'est un critère qui est important bien
évidemment mais qui re qui recouvre un
peu plus de subjectivité que les
critères hospitalisation par exemple ou
décès et donc vous poser une question
par rapport en déclarations déchets
grave et qu'elle était assez ses échecs
grave qui étaient majoritairement
déclaré donc encore une fois c'est très
vite et elle correspond à 7 à la
définition que je vous ai rappelé mais
il faut aussi comprendre les madame
rétine elle a dit que les les effets
déclaré les déclarations sont ensuite
analysés donc par les centres régionaux
de pharmacovigilance qui va qui vont
déterminer si effectivement les faits et
bien lié au vaccin parfois ça peut être
lié à la vaccination par exemple on
arrive on est impressionné alors donc
c'est pas forcément liés au vaccin en
lui-même et c'est tout le travail
évidemment des centres que de regarder
ce lien est d'établir cette imputabilité
et donc pour pour en finir effectivement
en a très majoritairement en termes
d'effets graves mais avec cette gravité
que je vous rappelle donc ce critère
médicalement grave qui est porté par les
professionnels de santé on a beaucoup
d'effets graves qui recouvre les
symptômes pseudo grippaux c'est à dire
les céphalées la fièvre c'est ce qui en
déclarations entre guillemets rutte si
je peux dire on ressort alors on a
également pour connaître comme hier
matip ans dont l'hypertension artérielle
on a évidemment pour
modern art dont les arbitres par exemple
mais très majoritairement dans son fait
le top 3 ce sont des effets qui sont
liés au syndrome pseudo grippaux
par contre si effectivement on veut
parler des effets graves qui sont liés
au vaccin est bien là évidemment c'est
ce que l'on va trouver dans le résumé
des caractéristiques du produit parce
que là dans ce document sont évidemment
après analyse non seulement des de
chacun des états mais après comme le
disait créatine et une analyse commune
au niveau européen on va effectivement
jugé que la lécher est effectivement lié
au vaccin et il faut effectivement porté
cette information à l'attention des
professionnels de santé et du public et
donc il va se retrouver dans ce document
de résumer de caractéristiques des
produits et là vous allez retrouver les
fameuses
thrombocytopénie thrombo thrombotique
immunitaire induite par le vaccin les
fameux vie c'est un univers enfin bon
bref
que l'on avait pour les vaccins à des no
adénovirus notamment et vous allez
retrouver ces faits très graves qui ne
ressortent pas nécessairement disons le
top des déclarations parce que en effet
pas la même volumétrie et pas
nécessairement de lien avec le vaccin
sur ces déclarations qui sont faites par
nous tous en première intention
voilà pour les quelques chiffres que je
pourrais vous donner
[Musique]
ce que le demi au coeur dit par exemple
myocarde et c'est un sujet important ça
mais myocarde et quel vaccin de
myocardite et combien nous allons la
mettre ko
concerne en effet c'est cela a été dit
par timimoun et donc on a à peu près
sans vie me lèche indésirables pour plus
de 100 millions d'injections tous
vaccins confondus donc ça c'est déjà on
est chez ça permet en effet de
d'appréhender à la fois un nombre à un
nombre sans limite chez indésirables
tout vaccin peut plus de 110000 tout
accès un confondues pour plus de 100
millions d'injections si on regarde sur
les peaux si on regarde en effet sur les
quatre vaccins autorisés donc est
utilisé sur le territoire national le
premier donc comme airmatic et le fax et
le vaccin pardon freezer by one tech on
a plus de 80 millions de plus de 80
millions d'injections vous voyez sur les
5 millions elle est très très
majoritaire on à 68000 cas d'effet
d'effets indésirables si nous prenons
moderna donc le spike vax
à peu près un petit peu plus de 11
millions de 11 millions d'injections
vous avez quinze mille cas déchets
indésirables
sur le vaccin adénovirus vague et bria
donc d'astrazeneca à peu près 8 millions
d'injections 27000 cas déchets déchets
indésirables et le vaccin johnsen qui a
été peu utilisé on a un tout petit peu
plus d'un million d'injection et nous
avons mille cas d'effets indésirables
donc comme cela a été a été rappelé donc
on a beaucoup de cas en effet soit de
syndrome suh de syndrome pseudo grippaux
ou ou quelques signes quelques quelques
effets en effet le terme de masculin si
on regarde en effet des myocardite de
mémoire nous avons à peu près un petit
peu plus de un petit peu moins de 500
cas au total de 4,2 myocardite
donc avec les vaccins arn messager comme
je l'indiquais donc à la fois le vaccin
comme mr mattic
le vaccin comme la nati de pfizer
bayonne tech et le vaccin sfax donc de
deux moderna et donc avec eux à peu près
3 175 cas pour le bac 5 aubière nati
donc y est très majoritairement utilisé
est un petit peu plus d'une centaine de
cas pour le vaccin moment donc on le
voit bien et c'est ce qui a été démontré
c'est ce que j'ai indiqué précédemment
et c'est déclassé en effet indiqué à la
fois dans le résumé des caractéristiques
des produits et des nautisme c'est un
échec indésirables qui a été reconnue
donc avec un lien possible entre cet
effet indésirable et la vaccination avec
les arn messagers des vaccins arn
messager qui n'ont pas été retrouvés
pour les médecins adénovirus
les vaccins des navires us comme cela a
été dit précédemment il ya en effet le
signal sur les thromboses atypique rare
donc ces cas de myocardite sont des cas
donc de résolution favorable donc la
très très grande majorité des cas les
éléments je parle au niveau national
mais aussi au niveau européen puisque
évidemment tout cela a été partagée
l'échangé au niveau européen on voit
qu'il y a il semble y avoir une
fréquence plus importante de myocardite
avec le vaccin moderne à comparer aux
vaccins de pfizer donc ça a été vu au
travers notamment de données
préliminaires d'une étude scandinave qui
a été réalisé mais surtout nous avons pu
le mettre en évidence donc avec le jc
kiffar avec l'étude épiphane où on voit
en effet une différence il y a des mots
car dit avec ses deux vaccins mais une
fréquence plus importante avec le vaccin
moderne et c'est ce qui a conduit
notamment la haute autorité de santé à
prendre une recommandation d'utilisation
des vaccins du vaccin moderna donc de
sfax plutôt chez les adultes à partir de
30 ans qu'il faut savoir trouver mieux
car dit
en effet la myocardite et d'occurrence
souvent une étiologie à virale avec une
une surreprésentation excédé myocarde ou
chez notamment les jeunes les hommes
avant et chez les jeunes hommes et donc
avec une concentration plus importante
en effet deux cas notamment chez les 18
18 29 ans et c'est la raison c'est la
raison pour laquelle elle empêchait
notamment dans le cadre de la stratégie
vaccinale qui n'est pas de sous l'égide
de l'année ça met de la haute autorité
de santé à la faveur de l'ensemble des
données et notamment des données des
fifa il ya eu cette recommandation de
plutôt utilisé modern age chez les plus
de 30 ans donc c'est vraiment tout le
cheminement c'est à dire on détecte un
effet indésirable en pharmacovigilance
on regarde ce qu'il se passe aussi en
taille de l'effet en pharmaco
épidémiologie ça permet d'aider en effet
à l'utilisation et à la décision donc
voilà en ce qui concerne et au fur et à
mesure les choses s'incrémente c'est à
dire que nous suivons continuellement
est là comme le disait en effet céline
minière nous avons des déclarations
110000 déclaration en effet c'est quoi 2
par rapport à une année puisque par
rapport à une année classique va je
dirais hors crise pour la
pharmacovigilance on a à peu près à
45000 déclaration tout médicament
confondues là uniquement sur les bacs
sound ce qui est assez normal nous avons
en effet plus de 52 millions de
personnes qui ont reçu un schéma un
schéma vaccinal complet donc de ce fait
évidemment il y a ça témoigne aussi du
bon fonctionnement et de la déclaration
et on a beaucoup communiqué sur la
déclaration la possibilité de
déclaration des effets indésirables et
de la déclaration d'intérêts des effets
atypique non attendue puisque c'est ça
qui est important
allez deuxième grand encore aujourd'hui
la concentration des médias car cette
semaine au sénat la commission d'
enquête commandée demandé par les
socialistes a commencé ses premières
auditions avec cette semaine des
universitaires on va les écouter on en
parlera juste après avec david assouline
qui est le rapporteur de cette
commission denquête inquiet le sénateur
socialiste de paris et qui pourra nous
dire un peu ce qu'il a pensé de cette
audition d'universitaires qui ont pu
comme cela aussi donné et bien leurs a
priori sur la loi de 1986 qui concerne
la concentration dans les médias on
écoute cette audition et on en parle
donc juste après avec un invité
je pense que cette commission qui se
réunit aujourd'hui extrêmement
importante elle se réunit dans un
contexte qu'on pourrait qualifier
d'urgence d'une certaine manière il ya
une mission qui a été diligentée par la
ministre de la culture le ministre de
l'économie sur cette question de la
concentration je pense que c'est un
complément extrêmement nécessaire et
peut-être un peu tardif
parce que vu
les questions qui sont aujourd'hui sur
la table on peut craindre que les
conclusions de
cette mission de cette commission arrive
un peu trop tard pour venir résoudre des
problèmes qui sont extrêmement
importants donc la question qui se pose
portes sur la validité des dispositifs à
l'oeuvre aujourd'hui en france pour
éviter une concentration excessive dans
le secteur des médias en fait on a on a
une loi qui a évolué lentement depuis
1986 si je devais faire un peu un
parallèle que je regardais l'évolution
de la loi de 1986 vu depuis 2000 21 je
me dirais que c'est un peu comme si face
à l'introduction de l'électricité on
avait décidé d'aller dépoussiérer les
chandeliers donc on a une loi en fait
qui malgré les nombreux amendements qui
lui ont été apportés n'est plus du tout
adaptée au contexte actuel et on voit
très bien
aujourd'hui avec d'une part la fusion
qui est en train de se produire entre
tf1 et m6 et puis d'autre part lempire
où l'emprise grandissante de vivant dit
dans le secteur des médias si on prend
la loi de 1986 je dirais qu'elle qu'elle
prend l'eau un peu de toutes parts mais
au moins à trois endroits différents
donc il ya il ya différents dispositifs
dans la loi de 1986 pour commencer on a
ce qu'on appelle les dispositifs mono
médias donc sectorielle donc là des
dispositifs qui porte sur la
concentration dans le secteur de la
presse alors ils sont doublement
insuffisant ils sont insuffisants d'une
part parce qu'il ne porte que sur la
presse quotidienne d'information
politique et générale ce qui veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui par exemple si on a une
prise de contrôle qui est en train de
de s'amorcer même si ça va c'est encore
sur le bureau de l'autorité de la
concurrence mais si on a une montée
qui accepte et au capital de vivendi de
lagardère média donc prise de contrôle
de paris match d'une part du journal du
dimanche de l'autre vous avez deux
hebdomadaires dont on peut reconnaître
je pense l'importance pour le pluralisme
de la démocratie en france qui ne sont
pas du tout concernés par ce dispositif
anti-concentration puisque ce sont des
hebdomadaires et pas des quotidiens
d'information politique et générale on a
eu au début de l'année dernière la
validation par l'autorité de la
concurrence de la prise de contrôle de
vivendi sur le groupe prisma médias
c'est pareil prisma médias vous avez des
mensuels les géo vous avez capitale vous
avez des hebdomadaires vous avez vous
aussi vous avez gala vous en avez un
certain
nombre d'autres ennemis pour ces mensuel
ni pour ses hebdomadaires la loi de 1986
s'applique puisqu'il ne s'agit pas de
quotidiens on reconnaîtra l'importance
politique du journal du dimanche je
pense qu'on reconnaîtra aussi une
importance politique en termes de débat
démocratique et de pluralisme d'un titre
comme le titre capital qui fait de
l'investigation économique donc déjà
indépendamment même de l'arrivée de
l'entrée du numérique d'une certaine
manière et cette fois en plus ne
concerne pas les sites internet
d'information
on voit quelle pêche par par sa
définition extrêmement étroites
finalement de ce qui fait le pluralisme
de la presse qui est une définition
qu'on aurait pu déjà interrogé en 1986
mais qui de toute évidence aujourd'hui
n'a plus aucune validité d'autant que
vous avez des magazines des mensuels des
demandeurs des quotidiens qui
rafraîchissent à peu près à chaque
minute voire secondes le contenu de leur
site internet donc ça c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose si on regarde
l'aspect seulement qui concerne la
presse c'est que les seuils de
concentration sont définies en
pourcentages de la couverture du
territoire national
ce qui peut paraître légitime pour la
presse nationale ce qui est quand même
un peu plus problématique pour la presse
régionale notamment si l'on pense aux
quotidiens départementaux quotidiens
régionaux ce qui a permis la
concentration
enfin la constitution de monopoles
régionaux dans le secteur de la presse
quotidienne de la pqr et la pqd en
france et ça s'est accéléré au cours des
dernières années ça risque encore de
s'accélérer aujourd'hui puisque après la
prise de contrôle par angie presse du
groupe nice matin c'est à dire
nice-matin var-matin
monaco matin vous avez angie presse qui
a déposé je crois aujourd'hui ça qui a
fait connaître à l'autorité de la
concurrence sa volonté de prendre le
contrôle intégral du capital de la
provence donc voilà on voit que sur les
dispositifs presse même si on s'en tient
on n'est pas encore rentré dans le
numérique hier qu'à la presse écrite on
a un certain nombre de difficultés avec
cette loi de 1986 sur les dispositifs
mono medien vous avez aussi tout ce qui
concerne la régulation des seuils pour
la télévision et la radio et là ce qui
est intéressant de voir si cette
définition d'un seuil à 49% non en fait
on s'est dit comment on va limiter la
concentration dans dans le secteur de
l'audiovisuel on interdit finalement une
entreprise de posséder plus de 49% du
capital d'une télévision privée qui
aurait plus de 8% de l'audience au
niveau national
sauf qu'en fait on est passé
complètement à côté d'une notion qui me
paraît quand même essentiel qui est la
notion d'actionnaires de majoritaire de
fêtes ou d'actionnaire de contrôle je
pense que ici si je vous interroge tous
sur qui est l'actionnaire de téhéran
êtes tous me répondent bouygues vous
n'avez pas dire ça peut pas être le
groupe bouygues parce que bouygues à
moins de 50% du capital de tf1 est ce
assez c'est extrêmement intéressant
parce que je pense que en termes de
réponses à apporter une manière de
modifier la loi de 1986 on voit que 49%
ça ne suffit pas mais que si on dit que
40%
ça ne suffira peut-être pas davantage et
donc il faut réussir à penser la notion
d'actionnaire majoritaire de fait il
faut réussir à penser l'introduction
finalement de règle qui limite
les droits de vote et le pouvoir de
contrôle d'un actionnaire qui de fait se
retrouve majoritaire ou en tout cas si
c'est la volonté
derrière ce que stipule la régulation en
tout cas si la volonté était de ne pas
permettre à un actionnaire de posséder
plus de la moitié du capital de fait si
vous avez entièrement le contrôle en
termes de pluralisme de l'information on
voit que la disposition est relativement
inopérantes
ensuite vous avez du coup un certain
nombre de dispositifs qui sont des
dispositifs qui porte sur enfin
plurimédia et notamment ce qu'on appelle
la fameuse règle du deux sur trois je ne
connais qu'une disposition radio une
disposition télé une disposition presse
écrite qui souffre d'ailleurs pour la
presse écrite du même problème que la
disposition presse mono médias et là on
voit aussi toute la difficulté puisque
le numérique n'a pas du tout été
introduit dans la réflexion par rapport
à la loi de 1986
ce que c'est pour ça quand je dis
qu'elle prend l'eau de toute part d'une
certaine manière je je je pense
fondamentalement que
cette loi n'est pas selon moi amendée
elle est à réécrire
à zéro en fait pour toutes ces raisons
et puis pour d'horizon
supplémentaires d'une part c'est que sur
leur régulation de l'audiovisuel et
notamment de la télé il ya que les
anciens qui est pris en compte dans
cette loi puis d'autre part le fait que
ça prend aujourd'hui en compte le
problème de concentration notamment au
niveau horizontal mais pas du tout les
problèmes de concentration au niveau
verticale du coup on a vu pourquoi avec
l'exemple de la presse ça ne s'était pas
appliqué à
la constitution d'un empire médiatique
par le groupe vivendi et après se pose
la question je prendrais l'actualité
immédiate de la fusion entre eux tf1 et
m6 et ce qui pose une troisième
difficulté avec la régulation actuelle
qui fait qu'on a deux autorités
indépendantes qui ont à se prononcer sur
sur cette fusion mais qui finalement un
cahier des charges extrêmement
différents d'une part la question de
l'autorité de la concurrence et d'autre
part la question du alors je sais pas
s'il faut qu'on dise encore c'est ça
jusqu'au 31 décembre comme je veux dire
c'est sa part par facilité la question
du csa qui doit se prononcer sur
sur le point du pluralisme et j'en
arrive aussi du coup à
la question des arguments qui sont
autorisés aujourd'hui
utilisée aujourd'hui en faveur de cette
fusion je veux pas vous apparaître comme
une espèce d'extra terrestres qui
seraient passés complètement à côté de
l'histoire
et notamment à côté de l'arrivée de la
fin et à côté de l'arrivée des grandes
plateformes de vod que ce soit netflix
que ce soit les autres fut tout à fait
consciente du fait que le paysage
médiatique a énormément changé qu'il a
énormément changé au cours des dernières
années et que ça appelle à interroger la
loi de 1986 et d'ailleurs je pense que
de ce point de vue là en fait tous ceux
qui qui sont pour par exemple la fusion
t il faire un petit saut contre la
fusion tf1 et m6 sont d'accord sur le
fait que la loi de 1986 est inopérante
sauf que d'un côté vous avez une
problématique qui est une problématique
purement économique et c'est pour ça
qu'on l'a pense en termes de
constitution de géants et notamment la
constitution de géants nationaux voire
de géant de l'audiovisuel européen et
d'un autre côté vous avez une
problématique qui est une problématique
en termes de pluralisme est ce qui est
relativement étonnant je pense
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on soit prêt
finalement
au nom de la concentration économique
qui devrait nous interroger en termes
d'information mais également en termes
de création audiovisuelle en termes de
production qui devraient nous interroger
sur la menace que font peser les gaffes
et les plateformes de vidéo à la demande
sur
le pluralisme de l'information des
contenus qui sont offerts aux
consommateurs on est pris finalement à
sacrifier le peu de pluralisme qui nous
reste pour résoudre une problématique du
surconcentration par la constitution de
nouveaux monopoles
et c'est ça qui me semble tout à fait
paradoxale voilà pour cette audition de
plusieurs universitaires par la nouvelle
commission d' enquête sur la
concentration dans les médias et pour en
parler j'accueille en salle des
conférences
donc ça les conférences david assouline
bonjour je vais vous le rapporteur
socialiste de cette nouvelle commission
auxquelles vous êtes aussi à l'origine
de la demande de cette commission à
qatana on a entendu ces universitaires
notamment julia cagé parlé d'une loi de
1986 totalement inadapté et qu'il
faudrait complètement réécrire qu'est ce
que vous avez pensé oui mais je pense
qu'il y à un consensus de tous les
acteurs et des observateurs pour dire
que pas seulement dans ce domaine dans
tous les autres domaines
le paysage audiovisuel et du monde de
l'information ans aujourd'hui n'a rien à
voir avec celui de 86 voilà les
intentions poser en 86 reste les bonnes
qu'il y ait une liberté de la
communication qu'il puisse y avoir une
régulation
on ne peut pas posséder n'importe quoi
n'importe comment et auteur qu'on veut
pour ce qui est des concentrations mais
on ne pouvait pas imaginer les
concentration verticale et horizontale
en même temps on ne pouvait pas imaginer
cette révolution numérique justement
après je les cages et on a parlé elle
dit cette loi ne concernait pas les
sites internet d'information
on voit quelle pêche par la définition
extrêmement étroite de ce qu'est le
pluralisme dans la presse elle dit pour
moi cette loi n'est pas amendée elle est
à écrire à 0 il faut il faut lui donner
une cohérence c'est vrai que depuis 86
il ya eu des dizaines et des dizaines
d'amendements parce qu'à chaque fois il
fallait boucher des trous qui
apparaissait dans la raquette est donc
aujourd'hui c'est c'est déjà quand il a
été prévu loi sur l'audiovisuel par
l'actuel gouvernement qu'il n'a pas fait
il s'agissait de refonder cette loi dont
bien entendu ça ne doit pas être encore
boucher des trous même si dans l'urgence
des fois évoluer les bouchers mais il
faut absolument qu'il y ait un débat
national qui lie à un projet est qu'il y
ait une législation nouvelle qui prenne
en compte la réalité du paysage
audiovisuel des usages des technologies
des acteurs aujourd'hui en présence
justement parmi ses acteurs il ya le
gros bolloré pourquoi est-ce que je
parle de ça parce que ça a été évoqué
pendant l'audition notamment avec cette
prise de contrôle de paris match et le
journal du dimanche et c'est donc c'est
des zones des hebdomadaires dont on peut
reconnaître l'importance pour le
pluralisme de la démocratie en france a
encore dit julien kg qui ne sont pas
concernés par le dispositif
anti-concentration on le voit ça y est
le groupe bolloré s'invite dans les
travaux de la commission denquête oui
les rives autour de ce qui se passe mais
de bien entendu tout on en parle mais
vous voyez bien qu'il ya aussi une
actualité avec une concentration qui n'a
pas le même caractère qui n'a pas les
mêmes objectifs
avec tf1 et m6 sylvia tout ce qui s'est
passé à bas bruit pendant une vingtaine
d'années dans le secteur de la presse de
la pqr quotidienne où on voit qu'il ya
aujourd'hui cinq six groupes essentiels
qui possède l'essentiel de cette presse
écrite et la plus lue par les français
donc voilà je sais bien que ça va
mobiliser beaucoup le groupe bolloré
parce qu'il ya outre le sujet de la
concentration et des prises de contrôle
dans différents domaines il y a y
compris l'édition ce qui est une
nouveauté importante
il y à aussi
comment vous dire un problème plus
général qui permet
de faire ce que fait le groupe vivendi
et et bolloré c'est c'est un contexte
donc je sais que beaucoup vouloir parler
que de ça je le comprends parce que il y
a au delà d'un projet économique un
projet qui semble politiques et
idéologiques
et dangereux à mon sens comme à beaucoup
de républicains mais on va travailler
sur l'ensemble du sujet on a une minute
encore pour évoquer un autre sujet qui
s'est invité au sénat cette semaine
c'est ce rapprochement des groupes tf1
et m6 puisque le directeur général de
bouygues était odyssée cette semaine et
il a dit que le statu quo n'était pas
possible notamment face à des géants
comme netflix qu'est ce que vous avez
pensé de cette audition
tg j'ai pensé qu'elle était très utile
de toute façon la commission denquête
elle auditionnera les propriétaires vous
allez rendre toutes ces personnes âgées
a bien entendu donc elle a été
programmée en amont c'est un sujet
aujourd'hui d'actualité j'ai trouvé
qu'elle était très intéressante
éclairantes
j'ai bien vu que il y avait une volonté
exclusive
d'autojustification et ne pas rentrer
trop dans les problématiques nous
posions les sénateurs d'ailleurs de
toutes obédiences qui sont bien sûr
interpellé par une chose est ce que
cette fusion
est obligatoire dans un combat on va
dire pour résister aux plateformes est
ce qu elle ne tue pas la diversité et le
pluralisme et est ce que aujourd'hui ça
ne crée pas une situation de distorsion
de concurrence dans d'autres pays david
assouline reste 30 secondes pour évoquer
aussi les propos de nathalie sonnac elle
et ancien membre du csa et elle a parlé
notamment de cette question de
l'assèchement des recettes publicitaires
par les gars femmes et qui poussent les
médias français à la concentration
qu'est ce que vous retenez vous de cet
argument sur le rôle des gars femmes
justement qui parce qu'ils sont c'est le
prince le qui force le sait c'est le
principal argument de ceux qui nous
parlent de concentration et qui
justifient les concentrations moi je
n'ai pas ce point de vue parce que je
pense qu'aujourd'hui les plus grandes
concentrations y compris celles
envisagées un tf1 et m6 ne permettent
pas d'être en concurrence avec lena
femmes qui sont à d'autres échelles
quand l'ensemble du monde de
l'audiovisuel français dépensent 6
milliards en cinq ans c'est hors sujet
selon et que netflix en un an fait 17
milliards de dollars on va les deux
voies et je n'ai pas additionner amazon
et tout le reste donc il n'ya pas de
concurrence là tu aujourd'hui la
concurrence doit se faire dans l'offre
la qualité la diversité et en
faisant vivre notre modèle on va pas
essayer de copier des modèles qui on
voit tous les effets néfastes qui sont
en termes culturels et d'information des
systèmes verticaux qui tue la démocratie
à petit feu eh bien merci merci merci
pour cette analyse on sur un veau
travaux jusqu'au rendu votre apporte 7
en mars prochain oui on a le temps
et alors justement à propos de cette
fusion entre tf1 et m6 qui est en cours
écoutons olivier roussat le directeur
général du groupe willie qui était
auditionné cette semaine au sénat il a
défendu cette stratégie de rapprochement
entre les deux chaînes face à des géants
comme netflix est alors que la part de
temps devant la télé linéaire est en
baisse allez direction la salle
clémenceau poursuit cette audition
ce que l'on croit et c'est la raison
pour laquelle autant bertelsmann que
l'actionnaire de référence bouygues
lorsque l'on porte cette opération notre
conviction c'est que la télévision a un
avenir on pense qu'elle a un avenir en
revanche que l'on croit ces cas n'a pas
un avenir en restant quelques allers et
qu'elle a une nécessité de se réinventer
et qu'il est important de pouvoir
proposer une offre en clair à l'ensemble
des français et c'est la raison pour
lequel on a proposé ce projet on avait
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre dans
l'évolution du marché c'est une chose
assez simple vous aviez
jusqu'à il ya à peu près 4 5 ans quand
vous achetez les contenus y avait une
règle assez simple les ayants-droit
chercher à vendre leurs contenus dans
autant de pays qui pouvait le distribuer
et donc s'il y avait 50 pays qui disent
qu'elles ont conduit les 50 négociations
pour vendre 50 fois le contenu et donc
ça permettait à chaque pays de pouvoir
systématiquement acheter un contenu dans
chaque pays avait un acheteur potentiel
pour un contenu ce qui a changé avec
l'arrivée de netflix n'est fixée avec
des poches beaucoup plus profonde et il
a acheté des droits mondiaux pour la
totalité des pays et il a acheté la
totalité des droits c'est-à-dire les
droits de vod de diffusion sur les
appareils mobiles et rejette absolument
la totalité du lot pour l'ayant droit ça
lui évite d'avoir à le vendre n x est
globalement ça eu comme conséquence le
fait que finalement vous avez une rareté
des contenus qui est en train d'arriver
puisque il ya de moins en moins de
contenu à acheter puisque les
plateformes achète ses droits
systématiquement à l'échelle mondiale
vous n'avez pas en europe de plateformes
qui achète les droits de cette façon là
ça se fait au travers d' amazon prime
encore une fois au travers de netflix
est la première conséquence de ce marché
depuis l'arrivée de netflix et qu' il
est maintenant difficile d'acheter des
droits et vous avez une conséquence qui
est que les droits ont augmenté
progressivement du fait de la rareté des
contenus qui est générée par le fait que
des plateformes et achète absolument
global vont
deuxième sujet que nous avons
c'est l'audience l'audience
l'audience de devant le téléviseur c'est
à dire devant le meuble que constitue
cet écran l'audience est relativement
stable finalement la question n'est pas
l'audience devant le téléviseur c'est
l'audience devant la télévision linéaire
télévision linéaire c'est celle que l'on
fait au travers de nos chaînes de la tnt
ou de nos offres de replay est ce que
l'on observe c'est que le temps passé
devant les écrans restent élevés mais le
temps passé devant la télévision
linéaire lui est en train de baisser de
façon importante et on considère que
d'ici à 2024 il aura à peu près baissé
de 40% et il sera remplacé par quoi il
sera remplacé par du temps passé pour
pouvoir regarder les offres de streaming
et donc on s'aperçoit que l'offre
qu'attendent les téléspectateurs elle a
évolué ils ne veulent plus simplement
voir de l'offre télévisuelle mais ils
veulent voir également
et des contenus tels qu'ils peuvent
découvrir au travers de netflix au
travers de symptômes également
d'ailleurs ou au travers d' amazon prime
ça c'est un changement important qui a
une conséquence ça signifie que la durée
d'écouté individuelle la fameuse des
huits qui a mesuré pour calculer la
façon dont on peut vendre la publicité
cette dérive est en train de baisser et
à la une conséquence indirecte c'est que
lorsque la dui lorsque la durée d'écouté
individuelle baisse ça signifie que vous
faites baisser mécaniquement le prix de
la publicité que vous avez puisqu'il ya
de moins en moins de gens pour gagner
télévision vous pouvez pas réussir à
vendin télévision au même tarif donc
dans un premier temps
[Musique]